la tendance du vote se maintient un
gouvernement conservateur majoritaire le
4 septembre
1984 brian mulroney remporte une des
élections fédérales les plus éclatantes
il obtient une majorité parlementaire
historique 2 111 sièges sur 282 le soir
de l'élection il est à baie comeau sa
ville natale il rafle eu 58 sièges au
québec à qui il a fait une promesse les
redonner une place dans la constitution
canadienne de laquelle il a été exclu
deux ans plus tôt
pierre elliott trudeau l'architecte de
la nouvelle constitution de 1982
démissionne en février 1983 après quinze
ans au pouvoir
ancien ministre des finances élu chef du
parti libéral devient automatiquement
premier ministre
arrive et les libéraux monde dans les
sondages et là il décide en plein début
de mois de juillet de déclencher une
campagne électorale ça fait pas un mois
qui est qui et premier ministre ait
déclenché en juillet
son épouse mila est toujours à ses côtés
dans les opérations charme où il est
passé maître
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
c'était sans compter sur le petit gap
bécaud fils d'ouvrier d'origine
irlandaise catholique qui insiste pour
que son fils étudie à l'université
d'abord à saint françois xavier en
nouvelle écosse puis en droit à
l'université laval à québec la politique
est une passion on le connaît encore peu
mais il sait faire parler de lui il
s'illustre dans la conciliation de
conflits syndicaux au québec et à la
commission klich sur le crime organisé
d'abord le chef conservateur doit
choisir la circonscription où il veut se
faire élire encore en nouvelle écosse
haoues mans où il demeure il choisit
manicouagan où se trouve baie comeau il
deviendrait le tout premier chef
conservateur du quai et donc c'est un
grosse gageure mais sa gageure à lui
c'était de dire moi je vais il faut que
les québécois les francophones prennent
la place leur place dans le parti
conservateur et je dois donner l'exemple
doit montrer que j'y crois il faut dire
que john turner a fait une mauvaise
campagne décousu mal organisé on
retiendra un incident particulier
[Musique]
oui avait des mains baladeuses
y avait tapé la fesse de la présidente
du parti libéral qui avait fait des
blagues là dessus
disons que
c'est lui qui voulait donner une image
de modernité du parti donc ça donnait
plutôt des images dans ces régions mais
surtout il ya ce débat télévisé
historique john tanner reproche un brin
mulroney d'être tolérant matière de
corruption alors qu'il a hérité de
pierre trudeau de centaines de
nominations politiques
et leur monsieur mulroney rentrer dans
le tas en disant c'est vous moi je me
suis excusé pour faire des blagues vous
vous devriez vous excuser pour avoir
cette co
pilote matthew turner sur la défensive
dit ben j'avais pas le choix je vais pas
le choix et l'homme souvent rhône et
sort le job de la gauche en disant vous
aviez le choix assez vous avez impliqué
votre leadership vous auriez pu faire
mieux puis monsieur tron tout ce que
trouve à répéter si j'avais pas le choix
j'avais pas le choix c'est un accord
technique
mais la victoire se joue en grande
partie dans le fameux discours de cette
île où brian mulroney s'engagent
fermement envers les québécois je sais
que bien des québécois et des
québécoises ne seront pas contente de
simples paroles il faudrait donner des
gages et poser des gestes pour atteindre
l'objectif que je me suis associé et que
je réitère ici afin de nous du prochain
gouvernement conservateur nous allons
espérons le et de bonne foi convaincre
l'assemblée nationale du québec de
donner son assentiment à la nouvelle
constitution canadienne avec honneur et
enthousiasme
promesses à des québécois qui votaient
massivement pour les libéraux de pierre
elliott trudeau en 1991 référendum sur
l'indépendance du québec
monsieur trudeau avait pris un
engagement nous mettons nos sièges en
jeu pour la pour avoir du changement
nous avons compris le message des
québécois et nous allons apporter du
changement
deux ans plus tard en 1982 après la
défaite du camp du oui c'est ce qui fait
il rapatrie la construction avec
l'accord de toutes les provinces sauf le
québec un accord négocié en pleine nuit
qu'on présente au petit déjeuner à à
rené lévesque comme fait accompli
est absolument pas question pour un
gouvernement québécois qui se respecte
d'accepter une pareille évolution et
donc il ya eu un sentiment chez beaucoup
de québécois nationalistes pas
nécessairement indépendantiste qu' il y
avait eu une trahison des promesses qui
avaient été faites en 1981 et c'était
leur première occasion de rendre
jugement sur cette situation là aussi et
là arrive le discours de sept îles sur
la réconciliation nationale et les
québécois se disent bien voici une offre
honorable
et ils y ont souscrit très fort
dès le débat télévisé les sondages
montraient un fort en versements de
tendance quand en revenant de sept îles
à travers charlevoix et en remontant
triomphalement la grande allée de québec
brian mulroney savait qu'il avait gagné
on n'a jamais vu une victoire de cette
ampleur-là 50 pour cent du vote une
majorité de sièges dans chacune des
provinces
211 député
du jamais vu ça a jamais été égalée
depuis
sa presque trop
brian mulroney sera par la suite un
premier ministre de transformation on
lui doit l'accord de libre échange avec
les états unis puis le mexique la tps de
réforme audacieuse car très contestée et
aussi l'accord sur les plus acides
il n'a pas hésité à confronter ronald
reagan et margaret thatcher dans la
lutte contre l'apartheid en afrique du
sud mais il a échoué dans ce qui lui
tenait le plus à coeur et qui a dominé
ces demandes à faire reconnaître la
société distincte du québec par le reste
du canada cet échec dira-t-il a été le
pire moment de ma vie en politique et
peut-être même de ma vie entière